[Musique]
d
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous
donc c'est aujourd'hui notre
6e 6e convention donc je reviens pas sur
les conventions précédentes
merci d'être d'abord toujours aussi
fidèle à nos à nos conventions puisque
on est si on prend la fourchette large
entre 60 et 100 mille vue à chacune de
nos de nos conventions donc merci de
nous suivre
aujourd'hui la convention porte sur
alimentation et agriculture
nous sommes face à un double voire un
triple défi en réalité d'abord c'est un
défi démographique il y à 60 ans il y
avait 3 milliards un peu plus de 3
milliards d'habitants sur la planète
aujourd'hui on est à plus de 7 milliards
dans 30 ans aura plus de 10 milliards
d'habitants sur la planète donc à partir
de là comment on répond à l'augmentation
de cette demande alimentaire il y a deux
possibilités on peut en imaginer
d'autres m'enfin il y en a deux qui sont
assez claires soit on l'on met davantage
de terres en culture mais ça voudrait
dire à ce moment là qu'on s'engage dans
un grand plan de déforestation je pense
que personne n'est prêt à s'engager dans
cette voie
soit on produit davantage sur les terres
qu'ils existent et le défi qu'est le
nôtre c'est de pouvoir produire
davantage et de produire mieux
en répondant parallèlement à une demande
sociétale de plus en plus forte à savoir
de pouvoir tracer nos produits
d'identifier nos produits de pouvoir
rechercher des qualités gustatives que
l'on a que l'on a perdus ou que l'on
veut que l'on veut retrouver et donc
l'agriculture a su à chaque fois
s'adapter je le dis souvent je pense
qu'il n'y a pas un secteur d'activité
qui a été capable de se remettre en
cause comme le monde agricole a su le
faire en tout en toute circonstance et
en permanence s'adapter et donc
aujourd'hui produire plus et produire
mieux je pense que c'est tout à fait
possible avec une autre attente qui est
sociétale mais qui aussi celle des
agriculteurs c'est d'utiliser le moins
d'intrants possible parce que tout
d'abord pour des raisons économiques
mais au delà des raisons économiques
parce que les agriculteurs sont des
citoyens comme les autres et ils ont
envie effectivement d'essayer de
diminuer au maximum l'utilisation des
produits phytopharmaceutiques
ça veut dire aussi d'avoir des variétés
qui répondent à l'ensemble des attentes
donc voilà la situation les enjeux tels
qu'ils se taisent qui se présentent à
nous et ce défi c'est aussi celui de la
présence sur la scène internationale
parce que la france grands pays
agricoles
mais aujourd'hui on voit bien que en
réalité on a perdu notre autosuffisance
alimentaire c'est à dire que si on
retire les grands crus de bordeaux de
bourgogne de champagne ou encore le
cognac
eh bien on s'aperçoit qu'en réalité on a
plus l'autosuffisance alimentaire en
france et pourtant la france doit jouer
sur la scène internationale sur la la
réponse à cette augmentation de la
demande alimentaire nous devons être
présente parce que nous sommes d'abord
un grand pays agricole avec un savoir
faire qui est incontestée et puis c'est
un enjeu géostratégique
donc voilà les données de l'équation
elle n'est pas simple à résoudre mais
nous allons avoir une série de
d'intervenants qui vont pouvoir nous
apporter différents éclairages et nous
nous avons travaillé depuis maintenant
quelques mois sur ce sujet alors pour
ouvrir cette séance j'ai donné ma parole
à quelqu'un qui mieux que personne peut
parler de l'alimentation nous avons la
chance d'avoir guy savoy à nos côtés à
nos grands chefs très grands chefs
étoilés
fait rayonner l'art de la table et la
cuisine bien sûr en france mais dans le
monde entier parce que cette la france
est aussi s'associent cette préférence
sur la bonne table sur la bonne cuisine
et en cuisine bien avec des bons
produits
donc je vais laisser à guy le sera nous
apporter un témoignage pendant la minute
et puis ensuite on passera à un jeu de
questions réponses avec nos intervenants
dit merci infiniment bonjour à tous
merci monsieur le président d'avoir
convié je suis très en fait je serais
très impressionné par ce que vous
imaginez bien que lui le vrai discours
des cuisiniers c'est dans son assiette
alors je vais essayer bon de vous
montrer un peu ma vision à la fois de
bien sûr de l'agriculture qui est qui
pour nous le socle de nos de nos métiers
de l'alimentation
et puis vous dire ce qu'on ce qu'on
arrive nous cuisinier à faire avec les
produits que nous que nous apporte là
bas l'agriculture bon d'abord me dire le
premier point c'est que l'agriculture
est indissociable des paysages c'est
grâce à l'agriculture que nous avons en
france
cette diversité de paysages qu'ils
soient de vignes de forêt de culture
d'arbres fruitiers de parcs à huîtres
d'élevage des paysages qui ont été
façonnées grâce au travail des femmes et
des hommes mais pas seulement au travail
je crois que c'est le travail
l'observation surtout qui fait qu'ils
font la singularité de la france bien
sûr on rajoutera le le bon sens c'est
vrai que nous on dit toujours le bon
sens paysan le bon sens français tout
simplement
cette capacité d'observation qui
détermine que telle terroir telle
parcelle peut donner des produits
d'exception par exemple remarqué que des
sols humides une arme grâce une terre
riche en verre mollusques et protéines
végétales allait donner les meilleurs
volaille au monde une race unique la
volaille de bresse
autre exemple qu'un unique cépages le
chardonnay d'une parcelle à l'autre
associé à la sensibilité du vigneron pu
aboutir à des vins aux multiples nuances
bien loin des 20 techniques de nos
challengers étranger à cette singularité
des savoir-faire des bandes observations
et ce travail acharné tout ça continue
le socle de ce qui fait la richesse la
diversité et la spécificité enviée par
toute la planète de notre gastronomie
française
là encore c'est une somme de sensibilité
un large éventail de métiers je pense
aux pêcheurs boulanger ou charcutier aux
bouchers fromagers
tous contribuent à transformer
instantanément aux joies des produits
chargés d'histoire j'ai compris il ya
bien longtemps
grâce à un père jardinier toute la
résilience qu'il faut pour faire face
aux aléas climatiques
les gelées printemps les orages d'été
tous ces évènements qui peuvent en
quelques secondes
anéantir le travail de plusieurs
semaines voire de plusieurs mois
cette prise de conscience nous
responsabilise lorsque le produit arrive
dans nos cuisines
un produit avec son histoire une
histoire de labeur de passion et de
patience
celle de nos agricultrices et de nos
agriculteurs grâce à vous tous nous
artisans de la gastronomie faisons notre
marché est notre métier vous nous offrez
un choix quasi infini de transformation
et d'élaboration à partir de tous ces
produits d'exception la france en temps
normal
or cette terrible période de co vide
est le premier pays touristique au monde
et la gastronomie figurent toujours
parmi les trois premiers paramètres qui
s'imposent pour le choix de cette
destination
notre rôle consiste à mettre en scène à
travers chacune de nos maisons
tous ces produits et savoir-faire des
savoir faire qui sont l'idée d'identité
de la france et je dirais l'âme de la
france
cet art de vivre à la française est
notre atout le plus précieux aussi
précieux qu original ainsi l'inscription
il y a dix ans du repas gastronomique
des français au patrimoine immatériel de
l'unesco symbolise cette position de
leader toujours incontesté
nous avons influencé et la planète
entière
jean 2 pour preuve les nombreux
cuisiniers étrangers venus se former en
france pour ensuite apporter à leurs
pays respectifs l'envi de faire évoluer
leurs cultures culinaires ou plus encore
l' envie d'ouvrir des restaurants
français autant d'ambassade de notre
pays tellement singulier il s'est passé
plus de choses sur la planète autour de
la cuisine je lis bien autour de la
cuisine autour de la planète pas en
france 1 ces 20 dernières années que je
dirais les deux mille ans qui ont
précédé
il faut dire que nous l'avons échappé
belle
rendez vous compte les déclinistes et
autres prophètes de mauvais augure nous
prédisait dans les années 60 une
alimentation à base de pilules à
l'horizon 2000
or qu'est ce qu'on constate que la
qualité des produits ne cesse
d'atteindre les sommets les déclinistes
ont été démenties grâce à nous tous
je terminerai en insistant sur
l'importance des restaurants qui sont
les plus belles vitrines du travail des
agriculteurs et de tout ce monde de
l'artisanat qui contribue à séduire nos
convives étrangers et français bien sûr
et les habitués à acheter et consommer
français
il me revient un chiffre inde il ya deux
ans près de 13 milliards de vins et
spiritueux étaient exportés chaque année
car si convient d'étrangers les ont
dégusté dans les meilleures conditions
dans nos différentes maisons c'est ce
que j'appelle l'identité est l'âme de la
france un patrimoine à défendre
éternellement
[Applaudissements]
merci merci guise et c'est effectivement
une très belle mise en bouche si je peux
oser le osé le mot tout cas où celle oui
mais voilà mais je sais je sais que par
ailleurs guy est un avocat inlassable de
la cause de tous ses amis restaurateurs
pour qu'on puisse réouvrir le plus
rapidement le plus rapidement possible
parce que c'était j'ai parlé
d'agriculture le savoir faire des
agriculteurs mais c'est celui des
cuisiniers c'est de cette alliance
formidable qui fait qu'effectivement la
france rayonne dans le monde entier